the first thing I thought as a singer
having to do videos all the time and
having to time things with the lyrics
when you did the entrance and the song I
was like how did how many times did you
have to do that I think 27 was the
official take on the date because nine
years in or 14 years in order to figure
this out it was nearly impossible you
think that song lasts a long time that
song does not last a long time when you
got a carry thing in take off a jacket
open a closet door pull a sweater off a
hat put the jacket on a hand watching
Mauri the boss Marie Heller our director
she she confessed to me later on that
she blew it that she could have made it
easier because she found out that Fred's
blue shoes were already halfway tied
they were bigger than his feet anyway so
they went on really easy then the shoes
that come off are also bigger than my
feet so those come off easy but I had to
do the full tie you know crisscross
applesauce crazy the worst the rabbit
goes around the ear in the hole I had to
do that whole thing he only had to do
the rabbit around the fly runner oh my
god it was a nightmare I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this